euh en fait Ayem et et Vincent miclet se
sont rencontrés en 2013 a été l'amour
fou et puis leur histoire a été jalonnée
de rupture de coup d'éclat ils se sont
séparés quelques temps après la
naissance de leur fils est vide et
jusqu'à présent il se partageait plus ou
moins la garde puisqu'il y a eu quand
même des moments où ni Vincent miclet
avait l'enfant ni Ayem etc et là ce que
nous arrivait Vincent miclet aujourd'hui
c'est que Ayem aurait voilà été chercher
son fils qui est scolarisé au Maroc à
Marrakech précisément dans une école
américaine sans le prévenir et que du
coup elle aurait pris le petit avec sa
maman et que aujourd'hui il n'aurait
plus de nouvelles donc il aurait déposé
plainte et il a fait une espèce de
d'alerte enlèvement sur Instagram de
récupérer son fils ce qu'il a dit hier
soir Vincent miclet poster un message
sur Instagram avec une photo de son fils
lundi matin après avoir déposé mon fils
à l'école américaine
en complicité avec sa mère l'a enlevé de
l'école sans me consentement et jusqu'à
l'heure où je vous parle nous n'avons
aucune nouvelle de mon fils une plainte
a été déposée aux autorités marocaines
mon fils se trouve sur le sol marocain
mais je ne sais pas où qui compte puisse
le voir ou le localiser veuillez s'il
vous plaît mon informer merci alors
cette photo
cette photo de du petit a été postée
voilà
Vincent miclet Ayem Nour avait convenu
d'une garde partagée une semaine sur
deux l'enfant est scolarisé au Maroc
depuis la rentrée cette semaine qui a la
garde de l'enfant mais Vincent miclet
aurait refusé qu'elle le récupère comme
d'habitude c'est ça alors c'est oui
c'est skym dit c'est que c'est que
Vincent aurait refusé quel Vienne le
récupérer sachant que oui effectivement
une semaine sur deux ayem se déplaçait
au Maroc pour pour venir récupérer la
gare de son fils alors
en exclusivité pour TPMP ayem a réagi il
nous a donné sa version et au Maroc à
nous envoyer plusieurs messages audio
qu'on va écouter vous allez voir c'est
assez fou ce qu'elle nous raconte Ayem
d'abord elle a commencé par nous dire
quels étaient les relations avec son
ex-mari qu'on connaisse Ayem ou pas
c'est vrai que cette histoire
incroyable écoutez
relation avec mon ex-mari son chaotiques
pleines de chantage de menaces du
dictature d'harcèlement psychologique ça
fait des années que ça dure et que je
m'efforce de garder un sourire accroché
au visage pour faire bonne figure
publiquement
alors ensuite elle a expliqué les
procédures
sous-marie aurait lancé au Maroc contre
elle
j'ai obtenu la garde une décision de
justice française je suis épuisée ça
fait 4 jours que je ne dors pas que je
passe ma vie dans les tribunaux et dans
les commissariats là il a porté plainte
avant-hier pour enlèvement d'enfants il
n'y a aucun enlèvement d'enfant étant
donné que j'ai la garde et là ce matin
je découvre qu'il a également porté
plainte pour que moi je ne puisse pas
quitter le territoire marocain
c'est incroyable à dire ce qui nous
raconte vous allez voir à la suite c'est
un film qui se passe c'est un film de
façon depuis le début de leur relation
c'est très très compliqué entre eux il y
a eu des problèmes aussi de pension
alimentaire des problèmes de garde et
puis visiblement ce qui ce qui
empêcherait Ayem de revenir sur le
territoire français avec Kevin c'est
qu'elle n'est pas en possession de son
passeport donc elle ne peut pas partir
comme ça avec lui après comme dans toute
problématique de ce genre là il y a
voilà la version de l'un et la version
de l'autre alors elle nous parle
également de la manière dont elle a vécu
la médiatisation de la faire à son
ex-mari parce que c'est lui qui a
médiatisé l'affaire aujourd'hui en cette
nuit on a tous découvert ça on s'était
reçu des dizaines de messages regarde
j'ai trouvé ça minable j'étais très
triste pour être honnête moi qui a
toujours souhaité protégé préserver mon
fils les médias et la presse me
connaissent pour ça j'ai toujours mis un
point d'honneur à ne pas exposer mon
enfant j'ai d'ailleurs beaucoup attaqué
pour ça
alors c'est vrai qu'on l'avait on
n'avait jamais vu voilà oui oui elle a
l'air effectivement
très très sonné par cette histoire moi
j'ai eu Vincent miclet qui l'est tout
autant et qui a aussi notre version qui
est une version différente
voilà de lui mais c'est vrai que voilà
c'est très compliqué et puis il y a
toujours cet enfant qui est voilà en jeu
entre les deux donc ça c'est dramatique
pour lui parce que d'un côté elle elle
dit que Vincent miclet ne le scolarisait
pas de façon régulière etc et de l'autre
bah lui il dit oui moi j'ai récupéré un
enfant au mois d'août qui était pas
forcément au milieu de sa forme non plus
alors Ayem me dit qu'elle vient d'en
faire depuis plusieurs heures qu'elle
est complètement bloquée au Maroc depuis
le poste Instagram de son ex-mari
à l'heure où je vous parle je suis
bloquée au Maroc avec mon fils parce
qu'il ne souhaite pas restituer le
passeport de mon fils il a fait une
alerte publique sur les réseaux sociaux
je ne peux même pas sortir de ma chambre
parce que je j'ai des gens qui me
prennent en photo à mon insu c'est un
cauchemar je vis un cauchemar je suis
enfermée dans ma chambre là avec le
petit depuis qu'il a fait ce
pas sur Instagram je suis en panique
j'ai peur qu'on me prenne en photo qu'on
qui débarque qui me qu'on en vienne aux
mains enfin je sais pas je sais plus
c'est très compliqué les lois ici ne
sont pas les mêmes alors les vols
histoire qu'elle soit autant médiatisées
parce que Vincent miclet c'est quand
même un homme d'affaires spectacle très
connu voilà c'est extrêmement riche
exactement c'est une des plus grosses
fortunes de France 440 septième fortune
de France voilà il est avec voilà donc
c'est vrai que même lui de médiatiser
l'affaire ça m'a énormément étonné mais
là c'est c'est pour lui c'était la seule
façon de récupérer son fils c'est vrai
qu'en plus ayem est allé étaler au Maroc
avec sa mère et que ça a toujours été
très compliqué entre lui et la maman
d'Ayem c'est d'ailleurs il a expliqué
que c'était l'une des raisons de leur
rupture parce que la maman était trop
présente à son goût et que même des fois
il devait pour lui échapper aller dormir
à l'hôtel elle est bouleversée et puis
elle dit qu'effectivement son ex-mari
qui est un homme très puissant a quand
même activé tous les leviers au Maroc
pour que le passeport du fils
effectivement soit confisqué qu'elle ne
puisse plus sortir alors qu'avec sa
décision de justice française elle a pu
aller à l'école et prendre l'enfant elle
dit que c'est pas un enlèvement pas un
kidnapping qu'elle a fait valoir ses
droits
alternée elle était d'ailleurs aussi
d'accord pour pour apprendre parce
qu'elle est complètement bloquée au
Maroc alors rien nous dit donc qu'elle
vient en fait et elle nous a expliqué
aussi les difficultés qu'elle a pour
faire appliquer les décisions de justice
française au Maroc écouter quelqu'un de
très important financièrement d'ailleurs
il me fait énormément de chantage avec
ça en me disant constamment je suis un
homme de pouvoir j'ai une armée
d'avocats j'ai beaucoup d'argent tu ne
feras pas le poids je vais t'enlever
l'enfant de toute façon ta seule
faiblesse et l'enfant donc je vais te
l'enlever désormais tu verras ton à
l'avenir tu verras ton enfant qu'avec
des gardes du corps enfin bref je vous
passe les détails des menaces et de
l'harcèlement psychologique que je vis
depuis des années et que je n'expose pas
quoi j'ai l'impression de vivre le film
jamais sans ma fille
c'est un délire quoi l'histoire c'est un
vrai délire je j'ai un enfant qui est
français je suis française l'enfant vit
depuis six ans en France j'ai des
décisions de justice monsieur a fait
appel j'ai quand même eu la garde là il
détient le passeport de mon enfant
illégalement il porte plein de pour
enlèvement d'enfants et fait médiatiser
ça sur ses réseaux sociaux alors déjà je
mental 4 ans je trouve ça m'énerve
d'avoir mis mon fils sur les réseaux
alors ils se sont connus en 2013 c'est
ça en 2013 c'est vrai que c'est la
relation avec Ayem Nour a du coup
médiatisé cet homme très vite c'était
dans l'un des journals dans lequel je
travaillais on a été les premiers à
publier des photos d'eux très amoureuse
sur un yacht elle sublime avec un
maillot de bain parce que dès que vous
publiez des vacances on y sont toujours
très amoureux sur un yacht non mais
c'est vrai c'est incroyable tous les
couples
c'est pas bien vu par les pauvres d'être
triste sur un yacht
bon Vincent est beaucoup plus âgé
qu'elle a 23 ans de plus qu'elle elle
était bon assez très connue suite à
Secret Story donc c'était un peu voilà
une histoire d'amour qui faisait un peu
rêver alors selon Yann toute cette
histoire est en réalité un problème
personnel et n'a pas de rapport avec la
garde de l'enfant écoutez il y a 2 ans
il avait fait des pétitions sur les
réseaux sociaux avec des petits
blogueurs de merde de base étage Vincent
a des comptes a réglé avec moi ce n'est
pas une histoire de d'enfants il peut
voir son enfant quand il le souhaite
c'est un règlement de compte personnel
c'est un homme de pouvoir comme il aime
le dire à qui on ne dit pas non et à qui
on ne refuse rien en tout cas moi je me
battrai jusqu'au bout pour pour rentrer
tranquillement en France avec mon fils
et reprendre le cours de notre vie
elle elle dit explicitement que n'ayant
pas voulu revenir dans son couple son
ex-mari lui fait payer voilà c'est ce
qu'elle dit elle dit on ne lui refuse
rien je me refuse à lui et donc il me le
fait payer par exemple tu voudrais dire
qu'il voudrait reprendre
de nouvelles chances
alors elle m'a dit
exactement la même info elle m'a dit
texto Ayem son mari lui a proposé une
somme d'argent pour revenir avec lui
qu'elle a refusé
que Madiana refusé et que son mari se
targue maintenant d'avoir pris il lui
dit à elle j'ai pris ton sosie en plus
grande voilà ce qui lui dit comme si
c'était une ultime provocation vous
voyez dans l'esprit d'ailleurs fiancée
de Vincent miclet ressemble énormément à
Yem elle me l'a dit texto et si lui dit
ça c'est quand même bien à côté
provocateur dans la version d'Ayem c'est
la version
moi je connais très bien Ayem et je
voulais dire que c'est une femme qui a
l'opposé de tous les clichés qu'on peut
avoir sur elle on l'a fait passer pour
une méchante pour une femme vénale
égoïste en réalité elle est très
gentille elle est très humaine elle
adore son fils c'est vrai que
l'entretien de relation toxique avec
Vincent miclet depuis des années mais
pas de son fait c'est lui qui l'appelle
tout le temps qu'il l'a harcèle qu'il
l'a menace et elle vient d'en faire à
cause de ça et pardon mais on juge la
faire sans la connaître il vient de se
marier il paraît c'est ça oui pour la
rendre jalouse il a pris son sosie
parfait ils sont inventé auprès d'elle
et je trouve qu'un homme de 57 ans qui
multimeultime multimillionnaire qui a
plus rien à se trouver alors je tiens à
préciser et nous aussi on aime beaucoup
Ayem parce que elle est voilà chez
Mathieu elle fait partie de la route
mais vous savez vous êtes très très pote
avec
parce que j'ai vu aussi voilà non mais
voilà aussi bien sûr mais j'ai vu moi
les messages des appels donc je vois
j'ai vu des choses et je trouve ça où
sur son téléphone voilà et je trouve que
ben oui
et je trouve ça sur son téléphone sur
son téléphone qu'est-ce que vous foutiez
avec le téléphone je l'avais dans les
mains je trouve que
je trouve que ce comporter comme ça
quand on a 57 ans et agir comme un gamin
et voilà c'est bah je suis désolé c'est
la mère de ses enfants il faut la
respecter et mettre hashtag sorcière sur
un poste c'est un manque de respect
voilà c'est tout mais toi comment tu
foutais que le téléphone
fais attention
j'ai le droit de bouffons lui
un ami il faut savoir Cayenne bon là on
reprend notre sérieux c'est vrai que là
c'est extrait il est incroyable elle vit
très mal cette histoire son moral est au
plus bas forcément ce qu'elle nous dit
est très très fort Ayem euh regardez et
que quel que soit la version bien sûr il
y a un enfant exactement fini par
oublier qu'il y a un enfant qui a besoin
de sa mère et écoutez ce qu'elle dit là
c'est vrai que là c'est très très fort
ce qu'elle nous dit rien
j'ai peur pour la suite bien évidemment
parce que je sais que c'est un homme
procédurier qui a énormément de moyens
énormément de contact et oui j'ai peur
pour la suite bien évidemment parce que
même si j'arrive à rentrer en France
avec mon fils
[Musique]
il ne cessera ça fait cinq ans que ça
dure les procédures et qui me fait des
menaces et qui me fait du chantage et de
la pression psychologique et de
l'harcèlement psychologique d'ailleurs
je me demande encore même comment je me
suis pas encore suicidé avec tout ce qui
me fait depuis des années et je ne peux
pas et je m'efforce de de garder la face
publiquement à chaque fois et de faire
comme si de rien n'était de ne pas
répondre je suis épuisée je n'ai besoin
de la peine et de la pitié de personne
je voudrais juste qu'on me laisse
rentrer tranquillement avec mon fils je
me battrai jusqu'au bout et je ne
repartirai pas sans mon fils ça c'est
une certitude merci à toute l'équipe
merci à Cyril merci à tout le monde
alors Ayem vous allez voir dans un
instant on aura deux nouveaux extraits
puisque l'affaire a rebondi dans un
instant mais juste avant
il y en a qui disent que et d'ailleurs
elle va nous en parler dans un instant
nos prochaines extrait ceux qui disent
que c'est une histoire d'argent c'est
quoi cette affaire parce qu'en fait ce
qui s'est passé c'est que depuis leur
séparation enfin en tout cas depuis
quelques mois Vincent miclet verserait
5000 euros de pension alimentaire à Ayem
il se serait mis d'accord pour voilà
pour il lui aurait promis de faire
construire une maison à Marrakech afin
que ça soit plus simple au départ Ayem
voulait que la maison soit son nom
Vincent n'a pas voulu il a il se serait
mis d'accord finalement pour que elle
soit au nom du petit vigne mais voilà et
apparemment ce ce dit le clan de Vincent
miclet c'est qu'elle aurait demandé une
pension alimentaire plus grande chose
qu'il aurait évidemment
refusé et donc pour lui en tout cas du
côté du clan Michelet ce serait aussi un
chantage que qu'elle exerce avec son
fils afin de toucher plus d'argent de la
de sa part il faut savoir que dans quel
on va avoir la version d'ailleurs dans
un instant dans une garde partagée parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui étaient
étonnés aussi que dans une garde
partagée il y a le versement d'une
pension ça n'a rien à voir au moment de
la convention de divorce elle avait
obtenu cette pension et selon elle il y
a une volonté de la part de l'autre
partie de réduire ou de supprimer cette
pension et là à ce moment là ça devient
effectivement une affaire d'argent mais
au niveau légal voilà la justice avait
ordonné le versement oui mais est-ce que
ce que nous parle d'une augmentation moi
j'ai pas cette version j'ai qu'il
voulait réduire voilà alors lui qui a
souvent le téléphone d'Alien dans les
mains non elle a jamais profité de
l'argent de Vincent miclet après leur
séparation faut savoir qu'elle avait
dedans après leur séparation toutes les
dépenses étaient uniquement liées au
fils il faut savoir que comme Vincent
miclet c'est un riche homme d'affaires
évidemment il a des hautes attentes pour
son fils donc il y a des dépenses qui
sont très hautes mais toutes les
dépenses sont uniquement pour son fils
et encore une fois on l'a fait profiter
passer pour une profiteuse qu'elle n'est
absolument pas alors est-ce que c'était
marié Vincent miclet
par contre
ils étaient pas du tout mariés ils ont
vécu ensemble en trois ans et d'accord
ils ont eu
alors elle s'en est pris donc également
à Yem au blogueur et à ceux qui disent
que cette histoire est une histoire
d'argent justement elle va vous répondre
en tous les petits idiots les petits
blogueurs de base étage les petits
bouffons qui a sur Instagram et Twitter
parce que vraiment je vous le dis vous
êtes des bouffons sur les réseaux
sociaux sachez que ce n'est pas une
question d'argent si c'était une
question d'argent on en serait même pas
là je serai déjà au Maroc les pieds en
éventail en train de me faire servir des
mojitos et mon fils avec une nounou
donc vraiment faut arrêter avec ça parce
que c'est fatiguant vraiment vous êtes
fatiguant sur les réseaux sociaux je
peux plus vous voir
il y aura un dernier accident dans un
instant puisque on aura le dénouement de
cette affaire vous allez voir qui
rebondit c'est vrai qu'elle est victime
d'un acharnement sur les réseaux sociaux
et qui émanerait en partie de son
ex-compagnant Vincent miclet et on a eu
des preuves qu'il a eu des contacts avec
des blogueurs pour la dénigrer sur
Internet et en fait ce qui ressort de
cette histoire c'est que Vincent micel
donc c'est un homme qui a très bien
réussi sa vie professionnelle qui a un
homme d'affaire à succès mais qui est
fasciné par la chose qu'il n'a jamais eu
c'est la notoriété et quand il a
rencontré Yam c'était une énorme star et
enfin il est toujours très connu IAM et
il était fasciné par ça et on a
l'impression qu'il veut encore faire
partie de ce monde qui n'a jamais digéré
leur séparation et qui continue de
s'exprimer sur Instagram ou encore une
fois ça choquant de faire un poste à 57
ans en mettant hashtag sorcière hashtag
sur 57 ans
le visage de son fils qu'elle n'a jamais
dévoilé elle a toujours mis un point
d'honneur à ne pas dévoiler le visage de
son fils je trouve ça pas très correct
et pas très classe qui me fait de la
peine c'est de l'avoir dans cet état
elle est bouleversée ça doit être très
difficile pour lui vous allez voir un
dernier extrait dans un instant qui et
cette histoire m'ont dit oui non parce
que
en vrai c'est que effectivement Vincent
miclat a toujours été attiré pour par le
la célébrité et que aujourd'hui
effectivement
ça lui permet également d'être en
lumière après voilà dans ce genre de
d'affaires il y a toujours du pour et du
compte et chacun a sa version et avant
qu'on écoute le dénouement à tu
travailles avec elle c'est ta
chroniqueuse comment tu prends et
surtout je les ai connu quand ils se
sont rencontrés comme faisait le Mag et
c'est vrai que elle était très heureuse
il l'a gâté beaucoup c'est vrai aussi
elle arrivait je me souviens à chaque
fois un rolls devant l'énergie 12 ans
elles ont peut-être aussi la rose même
après leur séparation moi ça me dérange
pas du tout j'ai elle était voilà et
c'est ce qui m'ennuie dans cette
histoire c'est que vraiment je connais
je connais qu'une partie c'est celle de
Yem et c'est assez grave parce qu'il y a
un enfant je suis d'accord avec
Jean-Marie ce qui est vrai c'est qu'on
avait jamais vu le visage de son enfant
elle l'avait caché à tout le monde ça
c'est sûr c'est la première fois qu'on
le voit alors j'imagine que s'il l'a
fait c'est justement pour que on le
retrouve si les planqués quelque part au
Maroc donc mais en revanche j'ai du mal
à donner mon avis parce que je ne
connais que son je connais pas je
connais pas le couple on s'est perdu de
vue après donc c'est compliqué d'être
aussi pernautoire que toi parce que je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé
alors vous allez écouter ce qu'il y a
quelques minutes Ayem nous a envoyé un
dernier message en sortant du tribunal
parce que oui écoutez
du tribunal il y a à peu près 30 minutes
Vincent a fait la demande
de récupérer l'enfant ils ont refusé sa
demande ils ont pris en considération la
décision de justice en disant qui me
laissait l'enfant puisque l'enfant c'est
moi qui en avait la garde
en revanche en ce qui concerne le
passeport la restitution du passeport de
mon enfant
ils m'ont demandé d'aller faire d'autres
démarches parce que ce n'était pas de
leur ressort donc Vincent continue de
garder le passeport et nous souhaitent
pas rendre le passeport plus que le
procureur lui a demandé dans le
passeport il a Vincent un refusé et il
m'a demandé d'aller faire d'autres
démarches auprès de de la France du
consulat français pour qu'il puisse me
rendre le passeport
qui a été déposée pour enlèvement et
caduc et que maintenant la garde est
officiellement reconnue au Maroc comme
elle était en France Ayem donc je pense
que maintenant elle va devoir refaire
des papiers mais là c'est une grande
victoire pour elle quand même ce soir
qu'elle nous annonce donc là c'est oui
le tribunal lui attribue la garde ce
n'est pas un enlèvement selon ses propos
et on lui reconnaît le droit de garder
son fils c'est essentiel la seule
question qu'on peut te poser pardon
c'est si elle avait la garde de l'enfant
bien sûr pourquoi est-ce qu'elle avait
accepté je vais demander un jour ici
mais c'était pas le but dans quoi est-ce
qu'elle va accepter que l'enfant parte
au Maroc et que elle a une fois sur une
fois une fois une semaine sur deux au
Maroc voir son fils si c'est elle qui en
avait la garde ça arrive
elle dit qu'elle avait un document
français de reconnaissance de garde
voilà mais dans dans la réalité pratique
parce qu'elle serait bonnes écoles à
Paris il se partageait c'est une garde
partagée il se partageait l'enfant
va pouvoir revenir là ou pas alors ben
non parce que pour l'instant euh il y a
pas la restitution du passeport de
l'enfant il va falloir sans doute
considérer que le premier passeport
n'est pas restitué donc en refaire un
autre et là comme elle le dit c'est pas
de l'affaire du tribunal où elle était
là mais sans doute d'une autre
juridiction marocaine
le refaire en France le passeport Duty
déjà il faut qu'il puisse quitter il
faut qu'elle soit physique pour quitter
le territoire marocain elle elle veut
rentrer en France avec lui mais pour le
moment c'est bloqué incroyable